اهلا بكم بهذه التغطيه التي نكملها من
قناه العربيه من المركز الاعلامي في
الرياض بموازاه القمم التي تعقد في الرياض
اليوم طبعا كان هناك قمه سعوديه صينيه كان
هناك توقيع اتفاقيات والاهم فيها هي
الاتفاقيه الاستراتيجيه التي وقعت بين
البلدين للحديث اكثر عن اهميه هذه القمم
على المنطقه على العالم بظل التحولات
العالميه التي تحصل تنضم الينا او انضم
الينا بالاستوديو الاستاذ غسان شارب رئيس
تحرير جريده الشرق الاوسط شكرا على وجودك
وهذه يعني قيمه مضافه اليوم شكرا على
وجودك معنا استاذ غسان اليوم هذه القمم
تاتي بظل العالم متغير بظل ركود بانظام
العالمي روسيا همم لا يمكن القول بانها
انتهت ولكنها من شغله متراجعه هي اليوم في
اوكرانيا في ظل صعود صيني يعني كل الحرب
الروسيه الاوكرانيه كانت بظل يعني الهدف
منها هو كسر النظام العالمي الحادي اليوم
ماذا تعني هذه القمم بظل كل المتغيرات
السابقه روسيا
يعني لم تنتهي الحرب بعد
لنعرف النتائج لكن يرجح ان تؤدي هذه الحرب
الى اصابات عميقه في ثلاثه اطراف اوكرانيا
مسرح الحرب اوروبا التي بدات هشاشتها
واضحه وروسيا التي يعني سلما رئيسها بان
الحرب ستكون طويله الاطراف الثلاثه ستستنف
وربما يكون الرئيس الروسي الذي سعى الى
استعجال عالم متعدد الاقصاب ظل الطريق
ودفعنا باتجاه عالم القطبين مجددا على ان
تحل الصين مكان الاتحاد السوفيتي
نتحدث عن يعني عن روسيا وعن المتغيرات وعن
النظام اليوم
بالمقال الذي نشره الرئيس الصيني كان هناك
جمله ملفته هي خلق مفهوم جديد الاشتراكيه
او اشتراكيه حديثه اليوم يحاول الرئيس
الصيني المواءمه بين النظام الاشتراكي
القديم وبين يعني
الحداثه التي يطالب بها المجتمع الدولي
بما انه الامريكي منذ فتره قالوا له انت
لا استراس مالي لكي ينافسك ولست اشتراك
لكي نقاتلك او نحاربك هل يستطيع ان يخلق
نموذج من هذا العنوان الحقيقه ان البراعه
الصينيه ملفته للانظار انا ذهبت ذات يوم
الى بكين قرب ضريح موتورتهم لم يبقى من
افكار موت سيطونك الكثير بقي الحزب كاله
استقرار لحمايه الازدهار نجح ورثه موت
سيطونك في تغيير قاموسوسه من دون ان
يعلنوا نهايه الرجل حافظوا على ضريحه
وتناسوا الوصفات التي كان يقدمها في
السياسه والاقتصاد
وهذا من حسن حظهم ومن حسن حظ العالم
فالادويه القديمه لا تفيد في معالجه امراض
العصر
بمحلتين اساسيتين الاولى من العام 1939
الى العام 1990 تسمى المرحله الاولى من
العلاقات ومن 1990 حتى اليوم المرحله
الثانيه من العلاقات اليوم مع المواهمه
بين طريق الحرير وبين استراتيجيه 20 30
هل دخلنا بالمرحله الثالثه ام هي تطوير
واستكمال المرحله الثانيه
جديده العلاقات السعوديه الصينيه الحاليه
هي ثمره لقاء بين نهضتين بين دولتين
اختارتا طريق الاصلاح مع الالتفات الى
الفروقات الكبيره في نظام كل منهما عن
الاخر طريق الاصلاح وقرار التقدم كما اتخذ
دينهس اوبنج قرار تحويل الصين نشهد في
السعوديه
فلان كبيرا وهو ليس مجرد تحول اقتصادي انه
اشمل انه نهضه كامل لذلك هناك فرص حقيقيه
للمواءمه بين رؤيه 2030
ومبادره الحزام والطريق
من الداخل مع اطار انفتاحي مع الخارج
وطبعا راسماليه خارجيه هذا التغير ادى الى
تغير ايضا من تصدير الاديولوجيا الى تصدير
الاقتصاد
ويعني التنميه في العالم هذا التغير وهذا
التحول هل ممكن ان يؤسس لاستراتيجيه ثابته
وواضحه مع المنطقه مع المملكه العربيه
السعوديه تحديدا اعتقد ان العلاقه مع
المملكه العربيه السعوديه هي الاسهل ستكون
بالنسبه الى الصين لان السعوديه هي دوله
يعني قويه دوله ذات امكانات ودوله تعريف
ماذا تريد لم تعد السعوديه عالقه في
حسابات الماضي
السعوديه اختارت طريقها كما اختارت الصين
طريقها ربما ربما تكون الصعوبات
مع الدول التي لا تزال عالقه في لغه
الماضي في الحروب الاهليه في عدم الاهتمام
بالتكنولوجيا الدول الغارقه في تعليم
متخلف ومن دون جامعه متقدمه لا يمكن
الذهاب الى المستقبل
كيف يمكن ان يتم يعني تطويره والمضيبها
بظل المواءمه الموجوده هذا السؤال المطروح
اليوم ايضا مع ايران واستراتيجيه مع خصوصا
اننا نتحدث عن مرحله استراتيجيه بعيده
المدى بين المملكه والصين طبعا يعني ايران
دوله مهمه بالمنطقه بغض النظر عن السياسي
اللي عم تتبعها واللي بتساهم بيزعزعت
الاستقرار بالمناطق المجاوره لها نظره
الصين لايران اخذ بعين الاعتبار موقع
ايران وقدرات الاقتصاديه والبشريه
المواء ما يمكن ان تحصل بمعنى ان تلعب
الصين دورا اكبر بحكم انه صار لها مصالح
واسعه ومهمه في المنطقه فصار ملحن ان تعمل
الصين من اجل الاستقرار الشرق الاوسط اكثر
من ذي قبل وربما يمكن ان تمارس نوعا من
الضغوط على ايران على رغم ان ما تتسم به
الدبلوماسيه الصينيه هو الصبر
وطول البال واختيار الكلمات اذا لنا صياغه
كل كلمه تحتاج الى جهد كبير
تمام الدبلوماسيا الناعمه وهذا الدخول
الناعم للعالم همم يعني حتى لو كان هناك
ضبط للصراع وللحرب البارده مع الولايات
المتحده التي تتوقع ان يشتد باماكن معينه
بالفتره المقبله ان تستشعر الولايات
المتحده هذا الخطا اعتقد ان الولايات
المتحده
تنافس تصادم بين امريكا والصين لكن يمكن
ضبطه انا اعتقد ان ما يستحق الاعجاب هو ان
الرئيس الصيني مثلا والذي كان ذاهبا الى
مؤتمر حاسم اللي هو المؤتمر العشرين للحزب
الشيوعي حاسم بالنسبه الى زعامته والى
بلاده لم يقع في اغراء استعاده تايوان
بالقوه وهو ما وقع في
بوتين في اوكرانيا علما ان حقوق الصين في
تايوان تفوق بكثير حقوق بوتين في بعضه
لا تختصر اليوم سلاسل الامداد العالميه
اليوم المملكه عبر هذه الشركات
الاستراتيجيه تسعى لتثبيت معادله جديده
ضمن هذه المعادله الكبرى صنع في المملكه
العربيه السعوديه وصنعها في الشرق الاوسط
كيف يمكن تطوير هذه الجمله للذهاب بها الى
معادله جديده
يتعلق
بدرجه استقرار كل دوله
بامتلاكها الرؤيه
وامتلاكها القدرات وحسن الاداره ويعني وهي
مزيج من القدره الاقتصاديه
والحذر السياسي وبناء العلاقات وبناء
الشركات انا اعتقد ان المملكه العربيه
السعوديه حققت في السنوات الاخيره انجازات
متلاحقه التفتت الى المتغير في الوضع
الدولي
ذهبت باتجاه الصين ولم تنسى الهند ذهبت
الى الصين ولم تنسى الولايات المتحده ذهبت
الى روسيا ولم تنسى اوروبا من مجمل هذه
الصوره صنعت هذا الدور المفتاح والمحوري
والذي تقوم به اليوم
عقد والذي
حدد شكل السياسه الخارجيه الصينيه منعطف
بالعلاقات الصينيه العربيه اليوم بعد هذه
القمم كيف يمكن تعريف العلاقات
السعوديه الصينيه والخليجيه العربيه
الصينيه
انا اعتقد ان العالم العربي يحتاج الى
الصين لان لديها ما تقدم
ولان العلاقات مع الولايات المتحده تشبه
الطقس
قابله دائما للتغييرات والاجتهادات
بين العرب والصين ممكن ان تكون علاقه
مفيده للطرفين شرط ان يستكمل الجانب
العربي هنا لا اقصد السعودي
والخليجي بقيه الدول العربيه ان تستكمل
استعدادها الدور لا يلعب الا من قبل من
استعد من امتلك ادوات الدور وهذا يعني
الاقتصاد وهذا يعني السياسه وهذا يعني
الاستماع الى الناس الملفات ان الصيني
الشاب لديه امل بالمستقبل السعودي الشاب
لديه امل بالمستقبل
مستوى تحسين يعني اخراج الصين مئات
الملايين من الفقر انجاز هائل العالم
بموضوع النموذج الصيني الفريد اليوم يعني
الاتحاد السوفيتي فقط لانه اعتمد على
القوه العسكريه فقط
ومقصين تعتمد على القوه الاقتصاديه كذاعا
لنموذجها هل ترى بهذا النموذج نموذج نموذج
جديد للعالم بالمرحله المقبله
نقل النماذج انا اعتقد ان كل دوله وكل شعب
ممكن ان يصنع النموذج الاكثر اقترابا من
ثقافه ومن امكاناته ومن مستواه تطوره
التعليمي ومن تطلعات مجتمعه لكن يمكن ان
نستفيد من تجارب الاخرين
شكرا لك استاذ غسان على وجودك معنا وجودك
دائما يعني قيمه مضافه شكرا على وجودتك